tight security at this Kuala Lumpur
Convention Center
organizers say Muslim leaders meeting
here are taking a new approach to
handling the challenges facing the
Islamic world you have to start with
problem identification right what are
the issues that need that that inflate
the Muslim Ummah and come up with some
solutions or answers to how to overcome
them and not just talk about something
concrete the leaders of three Sunni
nations Malaysia Turkey and Qatar are
leading this initiative and are joined
by Iranian president Hassan rouhani
high-level delegations from Indonesia
and Pakistan are also here but Pakistani
Prime Minister Imran Khan cancelled the
day before after visiting Saudi Arabia a
decision made amid media reports the
Saudis are concerned the summit could
lead to the creation of a rival Muslim
body to the saudi-led Organization of
Islamic Cooperation I see the
possibility that oh I see as it was
envisioned let's say 60 or 70 years ago
may not be relevant for the future of
the Muslim world and the scale summit
provides an opportunity to the Muslim
leadership coming from diverse
backgrounds to deliberate more
extensively on this question I think
they are reading too much in this this
is nothing like that we are not going to
compete with anybody and in fact the
summit is is complementing it sounds
consuming like see this forum I can tell
you is not going to replace the whole
thing for everybody it's not going to be
a block also delegates say they are here
to tackle Islamophobia and promote the
interests of 1.7 billion Muslims through
concrete joint action and there is no
shortage of pressing issues to discuss
they include the conflicts in Yemen
Libya Syria and Afghanistan unrest in
Iraq and Lebanon and the plight of
Muslims in Myanmar and
indian-administered Kashmir the summits
organizers say although meetings like
this are often convened to try and
tackle conflict and wars in the Muslim
world
this one is different they say its theme
the role of develop
in achieving national sovereignty shows
reviving cultures and strengthening
economies are seen as means to
overcoming problems for that to be
achieved a strong political leadership
in the Muslim world a clear vision and
close coordination are needed to perhaps
the main challenge facing delegates at
this summit is how they will be judged
by Muslims with Wars people being
displaced and unrest across many Muslim
countries people say that summits in the
past have failed to achieve anything
substantial so when the leaders here
stand up in front of this board for a
photo-op they will be under pressure to
be seen to act hamid van al jazeera
kuala lumpur